this is not sure this is a chai tea
latte and look at look at all these
phone my name Emma we're not gonna go
get this I'm the host of see something
say something
BuzzFeed show where we tell life stories
and talk about being Muslim in America
very cold out here in New York and we
are gonna go find a good hot cup of chai
we're gonna be joined by our cab driver
Jamil gonna go to Brooklyn pick up my
sister then we're gonna go to three type
laces and sample the stuff they have
there to you what is just a part of life
you know it's a hard to good that you
know yes definitely addicting is do you
like cardamom unity no wow yes oh you're
very milk just milk sugar in there then
um how obsessed with China
yeah not about chai tea latte shy means
tea
so a chai tea latte is a tea tea milk so
what are they go to three places my
favorite place is John Denis then of
your favorite places
Punjabi deli woop woop and Jamil I'd go
to Hani you go to Han D we're gonna
compare all three decide which one is
the best cheap delicious
they feature let's do it everything's I
started working at BuzzFeed I'll go to
Chandni and grab two cups of chai and I
would give it to my co-workers I had
somebody describe it to me what's not
inaccurately but I would have no thought
of it as broth
so we're here at John Denis in Manhattan
we're here with this chef of John Denis
Mohammed how do you make your cut water
milk spices what the inside and that's
it to use it is gorgeous this is
international recipe I learned from my
mother as all good recipes Tom I just
learned so much I mean I've seen it but
not like that
that was our next level stuff oh my god
it's magical it hits yourself right oh
it's perfect every sip is just like it's
got spikes it's got crews like silky and
a lot of sugar I know you don't drink
sugar regularly I don't actually you
know after that routine if you come just
look good what would you rate it out of
five
definitely I'm gonna go for that because
I don't deal with I mean cinnamon and
the long some other thing you know it's
not my taste actually further but no
doubt is a very good thing I would give
it a five out of five I would give it a
four because it's too sweet for me
that's good by me I am I'm happy with
that
alright let's go - lets go to punjabi
deli let's do it
yes it smells so smelled like huh very
comforting I'm Emmett
nice to meet you you name it my name is
people you in the same goal in this
thing what do you put in your job in our
tea we put half water half of the milk
and then we add inside a cardamom ginger
cinnamon we have also the clothes you
will really enjoy this too so did you
always make it with a espresso machine
is always working 24 hours like a taxi
are most of your customers
taxi drivers yeah
I feel like the difference between this
and Johnny this you put it in a thermos
you drink it all day you open it up
there's like you can see the clove and
the cardamom and I think there's even a
slice of ginger floating in here yeah I
love that vagina
how would you give it out of course the
method of cooking little different yeah
do it me go to on a spool just one right
right to me it's a fight if the guy is
great and just like being in that cozy
cramped space just surrounded by like
smells of home yeah it's a 5 for me this
is really really good I would give it
maybe a 4.5 yeah but what's amazing
about it is they're in such a small
location let's do one daughter okay
because this is New York Zanna had to
leave for an appointment so it's just
mean Jamil uncle for the last place you
said you wanted to come in to handi why
did you want to go in the owner and the
other guy who works over there didn't
only so I hope is gonna make a specialty
pharmacy that is the key you get better
stuff
[Music]
what do you want over here so what kind
of try what you get belongs just a
little child it's a little different I'm
gonna have him disordering and speaking
or do my or do is okay but it's gonna be
better especially with an old tradition
Allah can actually enter on all that
time I bothered him you know so we got
three different types of chai here got
the regular tea on the Left we got the
dude but PT in the middle and we're
gonna see the Kashmiri chai downstairs
you might not believe it but it's
basically green tea that when you stir
it for hours and hours and hours on end
it oxidizes it and becomes pick have
some pink on my pants
okay there we go Jamil uncle is opening
up his good buddy chai we got seekh
kebabs chicken kebabs gave it to us
because that's the way it box learn is
do I guess we're gonna start with that
dude puppy chow it's your favorite right
the color is really good yeah oh yeah oh
yeah
there's no sliced rice for you look just
good teeth and good to you little extra
making a little extra meal of the next
summer the texture is amazing
yeah the texture is definitely your best
of all the three we've had how would you
rate your your child of five like I
don't like think about this time but it
is really really reminds me of home I
want to give it a four point five
nothing very comfortable to you I could
drink it all day honestly so we recorded
a conversation with Jamil uncle also for
the podcasts you can find that at
BuzzFeed calm so I see something say
something talk about New York and the
cab driver life rate us on iTunes and
subscribe and we're gonna do a lot more
videos like this in the future
[Music]